hi so my name is prabhan singh and today
it's really nice to see so many people
interested in reproducibility and
machine learning
i was not expecting this much audience
to be honest
so something about me first
i'm a research engineer and a machine
learning researcher
at openml project and tu eindhoven
i'm open science advocate as you can see
i work for openml i have been active in
python community from last three to five
years
and i was a pi data organizer for pi
data service and pi data tattoo and i
like europe
so what is reproducibility and let's
just talk about first
uh first uh i'll just give a small
idea of what this tutorial is going to
be
first we'll talk about reproducibility
what what is it and how can we tackle it
by using open mouth then i'll give you a
small introduction on what is openml
and what are the objects inside the
openml through which you can reproduce
reproduce um
through which you can ensure
reproducibility and then we'll get to
the hands-on tutorial so the hands-on
tutorial will be around one hour and
before that we'll do half an hour off
just talking about what we're going to
do
so
i assume any if you guys are here you
if you if everyone is here they must
have phase reproducibility in some kind
of machine learning workflow at some
point in their life
and
now the biggest problem we have with
reproducibility is especially in
scientific experimentation
because we have these big models like
gbt3 or dali and
they are not reproducible even
by
a big company so leave a small student
but there are also a lot of papers or
just smaller experiments by research
team who want to ensure reproducibility
of their experiments but not a lot of
time they can be reproducible
so
what's the main
reason we want to ensure reproducibility
the first one is
that students can learn from it
we can ensure
that our scientific experiment has more
integrity because it's reproducible and
that's how we verify if it's right or
not
and that this does allow more community
community reachability so this does
allow us to reach more people from
different backgrounds
and
different countries who don't have the
resources to or
reach to access the experiments
next one is about reproducibility in
machine learning so
what are the elements we need for
reproducing
a machine learning workflow or a machine
learning experiment
the first one is data
so i think that's one of the biggest
bottleneck that most of the experiments
face
is we don't have the same data or even
if we have the same data we don't have
the same
pre-processing workflow for that data
to
ensure the reproducibility in our
workflow and to make them make the
experiments again
second one is task so tasks are a bit uh
it's a little bit more how should i say
meta term that
tasks basically mean what do you want to
do with the data so if i have a data
let's say iris or credit c or any any
other data set
what what am i evaluating on that data
and which metric i'm using for
evaluating on that data
sometimes even some papers use their
custom metrics
which makes them also
not reproducible because
a lot of people don't know how to
compute those metrics
third one is definitely models
and i don't think i need to explain that
part here uh because that's what
most of us face
the fourth one is hyper parameters so if
you have a model let's say i give a
small pipeline about me about my machine
learning workflow but i don't give which
kernel i'm using or i don't give which
parameters i'm using
then it doesn't give you
the right model
i'll also just set my stopwatch here so
i make sure i'm on time and the third
one is performance benchmarks
these uh
i have added recently and these have we
have been working on recently
but
we think that these can be really
beneficial for ensuring reproducibility
in
the machine learning life cycle
so now let's talk about how can we make
machine learning reproducible again
now here we'll go and talk about openml
so how many of you already know about
openml
nobody oh wow that's surprising
that that's exciting for me because now
i can tell all about it
yeah
so openml uh i can even tell the history
now yeah so openml was this project it
was started by
uh university uh two people in
university of leiden so
it got started in netherlands and some
team from munich and
other countries together by a few
researchers who wanted to
ensure a global knowledge base and
wanted to ensure reproducibility back in
2014
and right now i'm a core engineer for
open ml project and i've been working on
it for the last three years now
and now we'll see how opening works
so let's talk about a simple machine
machine learning workflow what do we
need for a machine learning workflow
and the most important part that we
already talked about is the raw data
which
is being handled by data engineers
which then get pre-processed
we feed that data into a flow
so here we talk about flow basically
means a model
but
six to eight years ago there was not a
right definition for that so we just
called it flow
and then we trained that data
on on that flow
and we have a run or a deployment
generated out of it
so this is our current machine learning
stack
i think everybody is familiar with one
or two tools out of it
panda spark
are more of data pre-processing
framework you can include task also in
that
then you have these machine learning
libraries tensorflow mlr
uh pytorch circuit learn
weka i don't know how many of any of you
familiar with weka here
oh wow that's surprising
so we also ensure workflows for weka
which is not very common so
but if
uh that's also a good example because if
i try if i make a really good model in
weka how would i ensure the
reproducibility for somebody who doesn't
even know what is vega
and when you go to deployment you have
ml flow you have dockerized containers
you have cube flow
so
this is basically a small life cycle of
a machine learning model
and now let's talk about the objects so
these are all the objects which exist in
openml
and now we'll talk about what these
objects do and
what are we trying to achieve by
creating these objects
first one is data sets
so we have data sets and we have also
metadata with them so what is metadata
it can be information about classes it
can be information about feature
distribution
it can be more than 100 qualities
computed on a data set
so i'll give you a small example
of how d how do we do that in openml
so if you have a simple data set like
credit g which most of us know
you have a description you have features
and then you can compute a lot of
qualities on top of that
so you can have number of instance
mutual information random tree depth
max abdominal distinct values so these
meta features also do allow us to
ensure that if a data set we are taking
is a balanced data set or not a balanced
data set and what kind of qualities we
do expect from the data
to compute workflows on top of that
so that's what we refer here by data
sets and
and metadata right now we currently save
openml datasets in a very old format
called arf
you can though download them in csv and
other formats but
we have started migration to parque
framework this year and we will be done
by the
in next few months to have all the open
ml data sets in parque
second is what is a task so
i think i already explained a bit but
a task basically means what do you try
to do with the data
so
you just have a data set and you want to
do an evaluation on top of it so
you say okay i want to do supervised
classification on top of mnist and
that's my task
third one is a model
and
i don't need to explain models too much
it's pipeline their hyper parameters
and everything else
and runs are the configurations that you
have for the pipeline
and the evaluations you generate from
the pipeline
so
if you have something like that
this kind of also ensures you to have a
global knowledge base
of all this metadata that you have
and
this does allow us to
do a lot of operations on top of that
data
and even take that data and generate the
same workflows again
now we also allow auto annotation so but
this
uh part is not very relevant to the
today's tutorial
so if we have enough time in the end
maybe we'll talk about it
now
here is a similar a very simple way how
we use openmlapi
so uh is everyone familiar with python
here or there are also some people who
want to use r in today's tutorial by the
way
okay great because uh that we have faced
in the last time
but uh
so we have a simple python api where you
have this data you as users or me as a
researcher i publish my data i publish
my flows i publish my runs
and those get evaluated on openml and
those are then accessible through our
web ui
or through our apis in python r java and
c plus
this does allow us to have a concept of
frictionless machine learning
how many of you are familiar with the
concept of frictionless machine learning
here
so
okay great
the idea behind frictionless machine
learning is that you can share the data
easily you can import the data easily
and you can create runs on that
very easily so the idea is that you
don't have any friction between all of
these processes that you are trying to
do on top of the data there's a really
good resource it's called frictionless
data dot io i would recommend to read
about that if you're interested in this
area
we also provide a nice web ui for these
websites and these flows to make them
reproducible and to for you to also
allow if you have a data set and you
want to see which pipeline perform the
better so we have 10 000 users who have
computed multiple data sets
multiple pipelines we also have some
bots which randomly
puts pipelines on datasets and then you
have those on top of them to generate
these things
now
so how many of you have used
scikit-learn for his hands
great
how do you get data set out of psychic
learning
you do scikit-learn.datasets
and then you get a dataset right
but where does that data set come from
so fun fact it comes from openml
and uh we do have a really nice circuit
learn integration as well
so if you want to create a cycle on
workflow only you can just integrate
that in openml
you can just use that workflow and
publish that workflow directly on openml
so we do have a cyclone we do have a pi
touch integration these are in a bit
better
pie torch is a bit in alpha stage but we
are working on that
and now let's talk about
again reproducibility by openml so since
we have
all these exact data set algorithms and
flows used in every
experiment that the user performed
this does allow us to
have reproducibility in our workflow
a simple way you can just uh make a flow
on openml is that your import open a
mouse you have a scikit-learn
pipeline over there
you wrap everything into a one pipeline
object then you run a model on a task
which
i already explained you have a model and
you want to run it on a task and that
already gives you a
nice run object
so a run object has all these
evaluations that your model did on the
task and then you can publish that
object which will then be published on
openml website
and then you can also get the same run
sorry
you can get the same run here and then
you can get the flow out of it
what we don't allow in openml is to
uh upload weights of the flows because
that can become unsustainable really
fast
sometimes neural network can reach
around
10 gigabytes or 50 gigabytes for a
simple experiment
and allowing us to upload the weights as
well allowing users to upload the
weights as well can be problematic for
us
so when you go to the flow you go to the
schema
of the model and then that's you have an
idea of what the model is
and then you can reproduce that model in
by yourself
so we do have a
small team
and a small community
we have around
150 000 yearly users
8000 registered contributions
500 public more than 500 publications
have used openml
in the inside of them we have more than
20 000 data sets but today we'll only be
working with the active datasets which
are around 5000.
we have more than 8 to 10 000 models and
more than 10 million runs and this is i
think a
three-year-old slide so we have much
more now
and we have this is our small team
of people who
are volunteers to open ml project
any questions about openml right now
what you said something about
that again oh it's in a more alpha stage
so i have
create i was one of the authors for that
extension and
i did create it but
it's hard to publish for example few
things like
if i'm doing a transfer learning
workflow
that so you do have few bugs but
we are looking for more people to find
more bugs and let us know so that we can
change that
if you want to see all the projects
under open ml umbrella they are here
so you just go to github openml
organization and you can get
you can see all the apis the main core
api
and
blog benchmark suites and all the
benchmarks that we have created
one object i have not covered here is
benchmarks how many people here are
familiar with the idea of benchmarks
great so
what do i mean by benchmarks
so in open ml since we have all these
data sets and all these tasks
what do we can make a collection of
these data centers to ensure
something
a robustness of an algorithm or a
robustness of a system
because you just don't want to take
random tasks or random data sets and
say oh my algorithm can generalize or my
algorithm can
make
something
dataset or one more data set
so we do allow users as well to create
their own benchmarks so if i decide to
let's say
take all the all the data sets related
to heart diseases
and i want to make a collection of them
i can call it a benchmark and uh
advertise it to people that okay this is
my benchmark i think all the algorithms
which work on this benchmark work better
with
all the other heart diseases as well
but again usage so if the community
doesn't use your benchmark it's kind of
useless
we do have uh two benchmarks out of our
labs which are being quite widely used
the first one is openml cc18 benchmark
anybody familiar with that
no
and the second one is automl benchmark
so these two benchmarks are being quite
widely used by people
and
second we call uh benchmarks a
collection of tasks
so if you make a lot of tasks for an
algorithm to do
that's what we mean by a collection of
tasks slash benchmark
but what if you
do your algorithms on that benchmark and
you want to publish those algorithms
what do you call that so we call that
collection of runs there's not really a
word for that out there so
this term this was basically one of the
best word we could find so this is a
very useful object if you think about it
because
you have all these stuff that you want
to do then you have
all the runs which people generated on
those tasks
and then you can see
oh what what's the accuracy i'm getting
on what task
and which one is the best for all these
stuff combined
and this kind of thing can help a lot of
users to select better algorithms
and then use those algorithms to ensure
that they can recreate them and use them
on their systems
now let's uh talk about
now let's get to the hands-on session
i think we are already 20 minutes in the
presentation so it's a good time
any other question about openml before
this yes
uh yes
so
can you repeat the
okay the question was is there a way to
recreate
the collection of runs
that like i don't know if you can
recreate the collection of fronts
because they're already ran objects
but you can definitely access that
entire data in a data set format and
then you can recreate individual flows
one at a time
because what you get in a run object
is something like this
so we call it a study by the way
from the python api so sorry for all
these confusing terminology i know it
can be a bit overwhelming for
somebody who is new to this platform but
uh
believe me this works
so we call it a study and a study is
basically we have a python object where
you get
all these
task ids and then you the only thing you
get on top of that are run ids and setup
ids
so once you have those run ids and setup
ids you already have the access to flows
and then you can recreate those flows by
yourself
so you can right now i
you can recreate all the circuit learn
and r and vector flows
in openml but it gets kind of hard to
recreate tensorflow or pytorch
runs because if i create my custom class
in pytorch then openml only gets the
name of that custom class it doesn't
really know what you did inside the
custom class
because our job is not to
ensure recreating code because that's
what github is already doing we don't we
just want to recreate the model schema
so did i answer your question
uh
you can
i don't think you can modify a
collection of runs
you can just create a new object and add
run ids in that object for to edit that
run
but
you can if you mean that can you
manipulate the
statistics of the
models inside the run
uh
yes you can
i kind of don't get what you mean but
once you publish the run you mean after
publishing
or before publishing
so uh
if
okay great
so uh i've i have already added the
instructions for
this on the discord channel has
everybody
installed openml and cloned repository
uh does anybody have any trouble with
installing openml or
cloning the repository here by the way
what
yeah uh like just uh first let's uh
clone the repository install openml and
then we'll go through the
notebooks one by one and then we can
go through that
yeah
so shall i wait for two minutes so shall
i just start with the
yeah sure
by the way in the meantime this is the
first time we are doing this tutorial
for our developer audience
we are used to doing this tutorial for a
more scientific audience
so i'm really excited for your review of
this tutorial after that
um
so
i've had a question in the meantime
first uh
you all can first make sure that you are
able to clone the repository and install
openml python that's the most important
part
in between i had a question if openml is
more for research groups or also for
enterprise project
and what if a pipeline should be
reproducible within the team but not
publicly
so openml we do allow we don't have
anything private in openml by the way
so the entire website code
and the entire api code in the backend
is available for everybody to download
and you can create your local clone of
openml and just run it inside your
network
and that's how you can ensure
reproducibility inside your teams
we've had few teams who have used openml
deployment privately uh some big
companies have also used open ml
deployment do also use open ml
deployment privately in their
research team
more than that i don't think this can be
a part of a
machine learning deployment cycle we are
not even aiming for that we are aiming
for
more from a society or a
sustainable machine learning standpoint
where
if you want to create a research or a
scientific study then you can
allow users to recreate those flows
but if you want to create a private
model and you want to you want it only
your team to be accessible through this
and you want to use openml
then you can technically clone the
entire openml
even the python repository just change
the server
in the back in the just change the
server address in the backend and
you have a running local deployment of
openml
i hope i answered that question
okay shall i start with the tutorial or
anybody has any problem with the
installation
great
so now let's
open the slides and
now let's first talk about
so you do have access to all the slides
i assume here
and today we usually do this uh tutorial
in a more interactive way with the
where you can change a lot of
stuff on the test server but today our
test server
is not uh is in the maintenance so we
are doing it with a production server
which is also not an issue but
ideally you should not
i should i say change the data sets on
the production server but feel free to
do that if you want to
so
you can just
first we import the openml object as a
simple python object
okay this thing doesn't work
yep
now let's
do a small
data set list
oh so
i realized i kind of
added all the solution as well to my
tutorial slides
which i should not have done
uh i would say all of it but
yeah sorry for that but we can go
through it line by line and we can uh
change the data sets to analyze more
datasets
that uh that's what we can do right now
so if you do if you go to openmr right
now and you take the data list so this
is a very simple thing
we are trying to achieve here we just
get all the data sets
and try running it on your notebook and
see if you can access all the datasets
from there
do we have that already done
what
uh i added the link on the discord
server
so
once i have all this thing
now i want to do let's say
um this anybody able to run the first
few cells of the notebook any problem
with that yet
okay great
so let's say i want to do it with a
credit g data set or some other data set
and if i you can even query the data set
so if i say number of classes is more
than 50
i can even do number of classes more
than 20
and there i have this name of the data
sets
and
the number of instances number of
features number of classes
so you can play around with all these
data sets over there
and see which data set do you actually
want because sometimes you have
all this data set repository and you
don't
you want a particular data set but you
don't know which data set is there it is
so then you can access through this
now once i have the data set let's just
download some data set from openml
so how can we download datasets from
openml
easiest way is you have all these sets
here
uh does everybody know the link to the
website it's openml.org
and
let's inspect uh some random data set
from openml
so is everybody aware about the
creditory data sets let's
we'll inspect that today
the id of this data set is 31.
so let's go here
oh
so
uh i have not made huge changes in the
github repo though i didn't have enough
time but uh
we'll just start with the i think that's
where we left uh download datasets
yep so we'll start analyzing some other
ids of the datasets
so
like i said the first idea of
reproducible workflow is just to have
the data set and see how
what is this data set and what are we
going to do with this
yes
yeah sure
yeah is it better yeah
okay great
so when you download a data set from
openml you use a dataset object and we
use the function called getdataset from
openml
so feel free to go on the website and
take any data set you want
did somebody ask a question
okay great
so right now i'm taking the credit g
data set
it's uh this is the url for the data set
and
we have the authors we have the source
we have the citation and this is german
credit data set and it comes with a
small cost matrix as well which is
pretty cool
now this only downloads you the data set
object
if you want to download the entire data
set you just go with the get data
here we want to download data frame
and
let's just
call this
data frame is here now you can inspect
this data frame
and is everybody able to access the data
frame right now by the way
okay you're able to run that
so now i want to
do my simple split on the data set
uh in a circuit learn style
so
you always get uh
four attributes out of the data set
if you want to get categorical you get
you get the x value y value
a categorical indicator the attributes
name
and uh from the get
get data set now i just want to see how
it's looking
is anybody trying any other data set
then credit g by the way
okay great how start going
so field
yeah
now i want to do a small analysis
on this dataset
by
exploring the visuality of the data
so let's just uh go with the
simple bar chart
where we are trying to do a small
scatter matrix of the class
with the bins and
so you have the
one duration here and the other
direction on the other side
i made this tutorial for another data
set so i'll just get back to
how it should look like ideally and
which data are you using now
this one was created sheet31 id
and
if you use it for
the eeg simple data set which is 1471 id
then this one makes more sense because
it has the bars
plotted right
so then you have the duration
of the eeg samples and that what you're
trying to achieve here
just to explore the how the dataset
looks like
so this
no that's okay can you just show me the
notebook
oh yeah actually mine is a bit wrong
though
so the one you have it on the notebook
is should be right yes that's
yeah
it's a it's a problem with my matplotlib
i don't know for some reason it's not
showing rest of the graph to me
okay yeah
by the way you should have a much bigger
scatter matrix
because i did make it like that but for
some reason i'm not able to see that
in rest of it
so you should have something which looks
like
soaring
this
so you should have
something which looks like this because
that's what i was trying to achieve
but and the code is the same but
sometimes matplotlib only shows one
thing
i just might need to restart my kernel
for that
but that's where you have all the bins
here and you can explore the data
visuality here
now let's talk about the next element of
this tutorial
called task
so i will go through
few elements i'll go to tasks and models
faster
so that we can talk more about
benchmarks because i think benchmarks
are the most interesting part of this
tutorial
okay
so
now can all of you
uh was everybody able to run the data
set tutorial easily
you grab the data set you analyze the
data set you can grab multiple data sets
and work on top of that
the second one we'll be working on is
the
task tutorial
so like i already said
uh is this one fine or more
like i already said the tasks are
basically what you want to do with the
data set
and it's a basic it's a small list on
how do you download an and analyze task
so it's a it will be a smaller one you
just go
i want to take
all the all the list of the task from
openml for supervised classification
we can even do it for supervised
let's go
regression
and if i want to print
my
i have all these tasks out there
which do allow me this is a bit
confusing
workflow i could see that
but that's where you get all the
source data ids
the number of feature in every ids but
if you put in a nice pandas data frame
which it's not showing right now it
should look much nicer in a normal data
frame
but
let's talk about all the data all the
task openml supports so you can try
multiple tasks here
so if i go
to this and task type
you could already see that
we support
different kind of task types so you can
go with clustering learning curve
supervised regression and supervised
classification
the most common are supervised methods
because we don't support anything
unsupervised on openml
and then you have the clustering which
we sort of support but it's much harder
to achieve that most of the people just
remove the label of
the data to call it a clustering task
so
let's uh create
uh so everybody is able to list any
regression or clustering or
classification task i assume
by the way everybody able to follow up
with the tutorial or it's too confusing
if it's too confusing just let me know
because it's also the first time i'm
giving it to
developers
now i want to see let's say i want to
query the task so we provide this api
called task.query
and let's say i want to see between 10
and
100 instance i want to see really small
tasks
so i get
all of this stuff which has instance
between 10 and 100
and
instance is a number of uh values in the
data sets
yeah oh sorry it's a number of uh
instances inside so number of data
points inside the task so how many
data points
how many
flows have run inside the task
yeah so then you get this filter task
where you have all these instances and
let's say i want to see something really
big
so since we have
more runs here uh less runs for these
many tasks so you have less task id but
now you can see
some really big terms so
if you see the length of these stars you
only have 59 tasks at these many
instances
and now i want to see the 10 fold cross
validation on that
so you also get different option of
estimation procedures
so if i want to have more estimation
procedures out there
we go we call them measure
sorry not measures
evaluation procedures here
so you can take uh different evaluation
procedures
uh we have so openml what it does is
that when you are uploading it it does
take your estimation procedure in count
and it does take your evaluations and
count
and evaluate the model against it
whenever you go for
run model on task which we will get to
later
so right now we are doing 10 fold cross
cross validation
now you have
these many tasks which used in full
cross validation
so now we are from 59 to 24 tasks
now now we'll talk about a small
benchmark that we did it's called
openml100 where we evaluate where we
took
hundred different kind of tasks existing
from every domain possible
and then we try to
evaluate algorithms against that task
so you can also search it via a tag so
if you want you can assign your task a
tag
on openml website or openml api
and then you can query through that
so there you have the task
it's all supervised classification
as you can see the tenfold clause
validation
you have the target size you have a
minority and majority class size
this kind of thing it can also be pretty
nice because sometimes you want to see
okay i already have my data set now i
want to see the imbalanced data sets
which exist and i want to train my
models on imbalanced datasets
so i can filter it out through majority
and minority class size
so every attribute that you see here
you can filter them out through pandas
api but you can also filter them out
through openml api
so
that's how you have all the tasks here
and
for example if i want to
do a query here i can
this is basically a database query that
you write
and it get passed to the to our database
and through which you can get all these
data back
so let's uh we have a small task here
now we already see
so any data set which you use for data
set tutorial now let's do it for a task
so we have a small exercise here where
we want to see all the tasks related to
credit credit g
you can also take some
wait yeah now it will be better
so right now i'm fetching all the tasks
here from openml
in format of a data frame
and then later i'll try to print those
tasks
okay
it's taking a bit time anybody else also
trying to fetch it
maybe that's why it's taking a lot of
time
okay yeah
so now i wanted to do a credit g i
wanted
everything what people did on credit g
data set
or some other data set you can write id
or
name here of the data set and evaluate
it now i have all the things any
researcher or a student or
a developer did on this data set so as
you can see you have the task type id
which we say what you did is some people
perform learning curve analysis some did
classification
some even need clustering
and uh then you have a task type here so
we have task type id and task type are
the same
but sometimes
you can make it different but let's not
talk about that right now
now we have estimation procedure so
people use different kind of estimation
procedure on that data set
so now i know what these resource
results are being generated by
so some are generated by ten fold
learning curve some are by thirty three
thirty three percent holdout sets some
are by tenfold cross validation
so now you choose your evaluation
measure like i only wanted
one to run which use ten-fold
cross-validation or holdout set because
that's what i want to train my model on
and that's what i want to analyze the
run on
and then you have all the other metadata
that you can find
so not every task has all the metadata
because some times it just doesn't exist
now let's download the task like i did
here
i just downloaded it for 31 id
let's take any other id
as well and see what's going on with
that task
so if i
take any of the tasks let's
go with build classification
which is based on this well data set
i take the id
and i want to download this task now
okay this doesn't work
so let's just stick with the credit g
and i want to get this task and then i
have this task which did cross
validation
on credit g so
unfortunately in here the task id and
the data set id is the same but that's
not how it's supposed to be every every
data set has multiple tasks associated
with it so every task has a unique id
and uh then you are trying then we are
trying to do cross validation on that
here
and we have a cost matrix availability
here as well so if you don't have a cost
matrix then openml does not take account
for the cost matrix
uh do you know what's a cost matrix
first of all okay half of the people
know half of the people don't so
basically it's a cost per class
that you have and you can use it for
model sensitivity or you can use it for
calibration and other things
through which how you
find out how sensitive is your
classifier
did i answer it a bit better or i made
it worse
what
a confusion matrix is i think the one
you get out of the results
right yeah confusion metric is what i
get out of the result cost matrix is i
want to generate the result
but what's the cost for a false negative
or false positive
and that's that cost you can
account for while training your
classifiers
so here if you have the availability of
that you can train better classifiers
that's the yes
i'm not really sure about that
because
sometimes some people you can even
create a regression on top of this
and uh though it's a classification
problem you can just make the target
continuous and then
it might not take that into account
and if you want to do clustering on it
then also
you don't have
that cost matrix is just going there but
in scikit learn if a
classifier does allow cost matrix
to be taken into account
it does and this is mostly through the
evaluation so that openml is doing in
the back in itself
so openml is going to
put that in the metadata and then
evaluate so some metadata of the
performance do use cos matrix
and then you can see that
did i answer your question okay great
so now i want to play around with
multiple task ids
as well
so let's take
um sorry
yeah we have a lot of tasks there
which are sort of private
and uh we want to make this task a bit
private now because we are still working
on them and then we want to release them
to public
but
if it's up there you should be able to
access it most of the time
for example let's do tic-tac-toe
classification
so tic-tac-toe it's a really funny data
set it's basically
every entry is the
tic-tac-toe matrix and then you're doing
classification if you want to last
and it's a really problematic thing for
all the classifier because there's no
pattern in it
so it gets uh really interesting
what
yep exactly
so right now the
okay so
uh the question is if we can only manage
the task in the cloud or right now we
can make them private so the private
tasks here that we have are
not accessible to public at all these
are just we have we had a legacy system
at one point
uh which is still in the existence and
we are in the process of removing that
so
since it's a quite like around 10 year
old project
we've had some mess-ups and which
created some random task ids
and sometimes you can get the error that
is private or public but we are sort of
working on getting it right
but
currently users cannot have private
tasks
the idea in next one or two years is
just to
allow users to have private data sets so
that everything associated with that
data set is private
yeah
but but again right now their goal of
openml is just to completely allow
you to use it
uh by the way right now we'll try to
create a task does everyone have their
api key
i wrote on the discord to sign up for
openml
okay no problem
uh i'll just give a small one
about so if you sign up
you can just sign up with the first name
last name email and password
i have mine already here
[Music]
so then you can go to this profile page
you have your api key
you download your api key and
you can always refer to openml python
documentation
for more stuff
and let's just do
an example of startup
so here are some there would be an
instruction here or how to add your api
key here
i think it was in one of the notebooks
so i'm just adding my own api key here
so
try not to take picture of that or
something
yeah
and then you have this task which i want
to create so i want to create the
supervised classification task
on dataset 128.
so if you want we can just take a look
at dataset 128.
the easiest way you can access openml
datasets you can do openml.org slash d
slash id
and you'll be redirected to the dataset
page so i'm doing b and g cylinder data
set here
and let's see
so i want to submit that data set so
now i have this
task up
and now i wanna
i created this task and it got published
so
if i look at the task here
now in bng cylinder data sets
so
i will have
all the tasks associated with this data
set here
so most of the tasks were created a
while ago already because it's a quite
old data set
so might have you can publish your task
but if it's not new
we don't create a new task so if you say
i want to do supervised classification
on mnist
with the 10-fold cross validation
most probably somebody already created
that task before you
so if you try to publish that task uh
openml will just
not either give you an error or it will
say your task is already published
how much time do you have left
okay okay okay
okay i won't elaborate more on task this
anybody understood what the concept of
task is here
i thought this tutorial would be too
fast but it's apparently too slow
so let's go to
a small example
of what we want to do now
we have a task here uh
uh it's in the run tutorial yep
so i have flows and runs here and uh now
let's uh i'm taking the credit g again
here
and uh
i'm taking a k i'm writing a k nearest
name a classifier on that
let's do something else
anybody want has any other classifier
idea
random foreign
no okay
so
[Music]
we can do uh
decision tree here instead
so i have a small decision reclassifier
based on credit g dataset
feel free to make a new classifier over
there you can have random forest
gradient boosting anything
and
that's how you make a small classifier
and train it on openml dataset
but
now i want to
let's say let's go to the next cell we
can skip the cell this file is again
about
making a pipeline instead of a
classifier
so you can take another data set
which we took here
and you just have a category get a
column transformer a one hot encoder
and uh then you just
fit it with the you can have a
classifier on top of that and then you
have this entire pipeline that you
generate in openml
and now i have this run here so
if i have the staff so i took credit g31
i ran a decision reclassifier on top of
that
and now i want to do run model on task
what happened here
okay so i need to provide authentication
key
uh any of you got your authentication
key yet
okay great so
oh sorry i need to copy back
so
hmm
wait a second
okay sorry just once again i need to
configure something
and then i'll be done
so you can just configure your api key
like this
and then you have a
run which you run the flow why is it
giving me a again
okay we have a one hot encoder here
that's why it was creating this problem
so
since i take the decision tree
i'm just creating a decision tree
on this
but i have the string features so
right now it's giving me it's a cycle on
error normally so if you rather than
that if you take
this
x and
sorry my bad i did not see that coming
well let's we can just take another task
which does not require pre-processing so
let's take
rs task instead
so we'll take
task ide 59
and we can run uh
oh what the hell is going on here
so we can just do this
transformer object and
sorry i think i'm
yeah maybe there's some
what
just a second yeah
i can just take a small example instead
but basically you can
do a small run model on task from a
classifier here i can just put a better
run here instead from the docks
seems like i made a small mistake over
there
uh tough 59 is a
yeah it was a iris here
so if i have it here i could just take a
small example of
small decision tree here
for another task and
oh okay yeah
um
okay so
for some reason um my system is giving
me some errors but
is any of you able to run this instead
or not
which is already in the notebook
can anybody can anybody run it or
everybody's getting the same error
from the original one yeah the original
one if you run the 31 or 403 are you
able to run that
no
yeah
oh okay then leave it um
so the idea was basically to put a run
model on task here but because of some
problems or some bug i'm not able to run
that
but now we'll go to the more
most important part of this tutorial
which i wanted to focus most on but
didn't have enough time
is benchmark suites
so
now let's talk about how do we make a
benchmark suite in openml
so uh what's the benchmark suite it's
like i said it's the collection of tasks
and runs
and then if we have a data frame
uh first we can run
it's on the benchmark suites dot i pi nb
by the way
or okay
i thought it's already five minutes okay
so you can get all the sweets from
openml
and the moment you get the sweet
so for example i got
all these openml100 openable 6018.
if you don't give the alias to a suite
we just give a uuid
so and you have all the other ids here
for the feeds you can fetch
now if you want to download a feed for
example i want to fetch
openml 6018 here
you fetch this suite to fish the
description of what this sweet actually
does
so most of these sweets are made by
researchers but if you're a user you can
also make your own sweet
so now we'll try to create our own suite
you can remove this line
a configuration for example
and just add your api key over there
instead
so now i want to upload a suite so it's
a test suite you can write your
name here pycon
and uh
benchmarks fees so i want to have more
task ids for the suite
so i just create all the task ids
i'm randomly taking
a task id for the sweet and just having
the
eu ids over there so
will probably get the authentication
error again so i'll just copy my api key
from here
is anybody able to everybody able to run
this notebook
is everybody able to run this notebook
or still running the notebook and
creating any pro uh having any problems
yeah
i can imagine it's uh i did not account
that everybody would be accessing all
the same things from the same server
so we have some race condition over
there now
but i think that was the last part about
my tutorial
about how can we
improve reproducibility by
allowing different objects like runs
flows data set and task
and benchmark suites on
machine learning via openml
so feel free to contribute more to the
platform
and feel free to explore the website
more this was meant to be as an
introduction to this platform which is
quite huge to be honest
and
yes that's about it so do we have any
questions
well i think he also got one
no okay
they always give priority to the slider
so if you have access to slider
maybe print your question there but like
if not i'll come to you
okay so the we have the only one
question in slider for the moment can i
can anyone increase the benchmark by
using
augmentation data model training and
achieved
sorta state of the art
okay so we do have this uh problem that
uh
if you create uh
so when you refer to augmentation
uh you can do that and that's what we
prefer in openml that but if you want to
make the augmentation pipeline
reproducible as well
then you basically just wrap the entire
object like something like this
so you just go to your
flow and you
wrap the entire pipeline
so
i would then wrap the entire pipeline
with a column transformer one hot
encoder categorical features
into one pipeline and run that pipeline
on top of openmill
openml
so
yeah you can do that on benchmark but
the benchmarks are never referred as
just a single
model they are always uh entire pipeline
so yes
technically you can do that but i didn't
get the question completely as well
yeah well i think if you have more
questions they uh like people from web
can always
on github uh and yeah we have a few more
minutes to take questions from the
audience here so yeah
i i have one one simple question so then
if i go correctly in order to use openml
you need to have the data set there
right yes so the starting point to be
using for my own project is to put all
my data there actually uh so if you want
to make a
private deployment you can if you want
to have a private data set you can just
make a private deployment of it
but
this is more about reproducing
scientific experiments so
yes you need to have first the data and
then you build on top of it so
if you because in the end this platform
is to make other people reproduce what
you did
so yes you need data set on that yeah
but then what i mean is everybody will
have their own deployment because no one
wants to check the data and also many
times you cannot charge it oh definitely
but that's not what this platform is for
so the entire platform is for
reproducing what you did
and it is for reproducing scientific
experiments that
academic labs or industrial lab are
doing
and we want to reproduce those workflows
so you do
want to
ensure that your data is always the
first starting point
on openml if you go right now you'll
find even
five copies of the same data set
and that's not by
accident that's why
because some people
take the same data set and they apply
one hot encoding but they don't know how
to put that in a pipeline so they just
upload the data set with one hours
encoding and some people they take
different classes and they want to see
okay what if i make the data set in
balance
how would the data set work
so that's the idea behind the
entire platform that you want to make
this entire flow reproducible
so yeah like if you want to make the
data set private then definitely this is
not the right approach to go
but
then i think uh if you want to make
your code reproducible without the data
set then maybe github is a much better
option and open them up
thank you for the question any
any other questions in the audience
okay moment
thank you
do you have any experience with
publishers in the scientific community
so
do you cooperate with
the
big publishers like elsevier or
acs
nature
what was the question if i have any if
openml does cooperations with
yes no we don't do anything with the
publisher of corporation or anything
we
just allow users and researchers to
upload all of their data sets over there
and
we like
we also hire people uh students or
employees sometimes uh because we're
funded by academic grants
to
scrape the internet and take all the
public license data sets
to openml so if you go to openmr right
now you find all the datasets which are
publicly listed on google datasets or
uci or mldata
on the platform so if the dataset is
public license we just copy it and put
it on the platform
so somebody can copy it easily
yeah
but yeah we don't do any collaboration
with the publishers as far as i'm aware
yeah
thank you thank you very much for the
question i think we have time for one
more question okay
one question about the reproducibility
uh when openml creates this pipeline is
the seat always kept fixed because like
you have like this python seat numpy
seat pandas has its own manual seat then
cuda has like non-reproducible
algorithm that depending on what kind of
graphic card you use it like produces a
different output like how is this
actually handled it's like the seat
somewhere written down and like
the same
if you define your manual seat
it is and if it's in the cycle on object
it will be saved in openml adjacent flow
so you will see that user defined that
feed
but i know what c you're talking about
if you talk about neural networks
it's much harder to do with them and
in openml we try to make it as
reproducible as possible we but even we
can't ensure 100 reproducibility
because like i said uh if you create a
custom class
uh i really don't know what you did in
that and if you are not uploading your
code or somewhere with open ml
flow and data then it's much harder to
guess it
so definitely with this random seeds we
can't ensure reproducibility
or especially with this cuda custom
seeds
okay um
well one minute left probably till the
end very short question maybe
no okay then we should probably all say
thank you to prabhan for the preparation
of the tutorial thanks a lot